back to the Commons before Christmas no
carriage this time it is after all the
second Queen's speech in two months and
this time around it's less about style
more about substance for Boris Johnson
jubilation this Queen's speech not the
dry run but the real deal spare a
thought for this man heading in to watch
his rival enjoy the spoils of victory
you're in denial about your election the
thief furious his political career is
now coming to a close but the election
has opened doors for the Conservatives
familiar themes but with one big
difference a big Commons majority means
these pledges are more than just fantasy
as ever one promised Trump's them all my
government's priority is to deliver the
United Kingdom's departure from the
European Union on the 31st of January my
ministers will bring forward legislation
to ensure the United Kingdom's exit on
that date prax its path through
Parliament now finally clear but the
people's priorities extend beyond brexit
for the first time the national health
services multi-year funding settlement
agreed earlier this year will be
enshrined in law guaranteed funding for
the health services a promise to review
social care my ministers will seek
cross-party consensus on proposals for
long-term reform of Social Care they
will ensure that the social care system
provides everyone with the dignity and
security they deserve policies not just
for the gray vote but the young too my
ministers will increase levels of
funding per pupil in every school and
tougher sentencing laws in the wake of
the London Bridge terror attack new
sentencing laws will ensure the most
serious violent offenders including
terrorists serve longer in custody
the leaders had him back to the Commons
and that matter they disagree and
bitterly those who were swayed by the
Prime Minister's promises will be sorely
disappointed as this Queen speech shows
what the government is actually
proposing is woefully inadequate for the
scale of the problems that this country
faces but in this place the winner takes
all mr. Johnson not just planning a time
in power but a decade this is not a
program for one year or one Parliament
it is a blueprint for the future of
Britain just imagine where this country
could be in ten years time never worn to
undersell himself or his ambition I do
not think it been glorious were
implausible to say that a new golden age
for this United Kingdom
[Applause]
[Music]
in spite of the negativity in spite of
the skepticism
to deliver it a couple of months ago I
stood here talking about the Queen's
speech that was pure political theater
it was a policy wish list but it was
never in the Prime Minister's gift
well this election has given him the
perfect Christmas present a massive
majority which he can use to reshape
Britain in a way not seen since the days
of Thatcher all Blair it makes him one
of the most powerful post-war prime
ministers this country has ever seen a
prime minister with the opportunity to
build a new Britain and leave a real
personal legacy as others have before
him but his success depends too on
delivering brexit without damaging the
economy and keeping a wounded Labour
Party at bay
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster